de quoi vais-je vous parlais
d'équitation de mma du free fight le
saut en parachute
le triathlon la littérature je vais vous
parler de littérature
alors je vous parle c'est l'été et que
font les gens l'été et balises un petit
bouquin voilà au bord de l'eau chez soi
ou en sortie dans les transports je ne
sais pas c'est comme ça et j'en fais
aussi partie j'adore lire des livres
depuis que je suis ado je pense plein de
livres en tous genres je suis pas un
grand spécialiste j'en lis pas non plus
une centaine par an et j'aimerais bien
lire un peu plus mais bon il ya les jeux
vidéo donc faut aussi trouver du temps
pour les deux tu veux et je me dis que
ça pouvait être intéressant je vous
parle de livres qui m'ont
particulièrement touchés j'espère que ça
va vous plaire que ça peut vous
intéresser sera pas spécialement drôle
mais j'espère un petit peu intéressants
elle vous prêt pour le top 10 des livres
préférés ne cyprien c'est parti avant
même de vous parler du numéro 10
j'aimerais juste préciser que ce sont
pas des livres pointu aux caisses et des
livres très connu et celui ci
particulièrement c'est la méga base je
viens vous parler de harry potter harry
potter moi ça m'a marqué quand j'étais
ado parce qu'en fait j'ai grandi en même
temps qu harry potter mais littéralement
contre le tome 1 et le tome 7 en fait
j'avais le même âge que harry potter à
chaque fois pour moi c'était quelqu'un
comme si j'avais un pote qui vivaient
aussi une aventure et là je tiens entre
mes mains l'édition anglaise parce que
quand le tome 7 est sorti je n'ai pas pu
attendre la traduction je me devais de
le lire de ce pas donc j'ai foncé dans
la librairie à côté de chez moi dans le
var pour acheter le tome en anglais et
ce n'était pas forcément une très bonne
idée parce que mon niveau d'anglais
était plutôt éclatée au sol comme on dit
chaque phrase j'ai dû utiliser un
dictionnaire ou une traduction sur
internet après je les lui en français
quand même et là je me suis dit ah en
fait ça parle de ça ça ça ne servait à
rien jk rowling elle est incroyable dans
son aventure comment la créer ses
personnages et son monde et en fait ça
hyper généreux d'avoir créé comme ça va
des ados qui grandissent et qui nous
forge en quelque sorte ça m'a créé une
sorte de vie à côté qui fait de magie
avec tous ces personnages là donc je
trouve ça ou bien sûr tout le monde
connaît parce que les filles mais pour
effraction les jeux vidéo ce que vous
voulez mais quand même
l'oeuvre originale elle est absolument
incroyable c'est très facile à lire si
vous avez l'occasion jetez vous dessus
si vous adorez déjà harry potter il ya
un épisode du flou de caste spéciale
harry potter donc c'est un podcast avec
des fans qui parlent de la licence et
c'est très passionné on arrive dans un
registre dans un genre littéraire que
j'adore vous allez voir ça va revenir
très souvent avec mes livres préférés
c'est la dystopie vous connaissez les
utopies un monde où tout le monde est
heureux et dystopie celle inverse c'est
un monde où tu ne peux pas être heureux
cause des des règles et de tout ce qui
t'entoure ses démons triste mais tout
aussi intéressante bien évidemment on va
commencer avec aldous huxley le meilleur
des mondes qui a inspiré beaucoup
beaucoup de gens ça c'était au programme
au lycée moi je me rappelle au lycée
j'avais lu tous les livres qui sont au
programme et qui sont pas obligatoires
et tous les livres de science fiction ça
raconte un monde où les naissances sont
contrôlés on n'a plus droit de se
reproduire est en fait le gouvernement
il crée les embryons qu'il a besoin donc
s'il a besoin d'intellectuels il va
créer des embryons intelligence il a
besoin de forces humaines et ben va
créer des foetus qui sont spécialisés
dans la force mais qui ne développe pas
intellectuellement et donc du coup c'est
des personnages qui vivent là dedans et
qui sont de différentes castes essaie de
comprendre un petit peu le monde qui les
entoure et effectivement techniquement
ça s'appelle le meilleur des mondes
parce que c'est le gouvernement qui crée
un monde où il ya besoin de rien en fait
c'est bon les intelligents font des
trucs d'intelligent ceux qui ont de la
force on bat du btp et voilà tout le
monde est heureux sauf qu'en fait non
c'est pas aux gens de décider comment
toi tu dois être heureux et c'est ça qui
est très intéressant sa part un petit
peu dans tous les sens la fin elle est
totalement bouleversante
je trouve que pour commencer dans la
dystopie c'est pas mal du tout ça hein
il se passe plein de choses et c'est
très curieux et c'est trés aventis a
aussi inspiré un film qui s'appelle
bienvenue à gattaca
c'est un film de science fiction on
scanne ton adn on va savoir déjà ce que
tu vas faire dans la vie quoique que ce
soir donc aldous huxley meilleur blaze
et meilleur livre tu as tout a tout
déchiré pires critiques littéraires moi
je n'ai vu que lui déconseille et aldous
trop bien
êtes vous prêt pour le retour de la méga
base sherlock holmes de sir arthur conan
doyle
clin d'oeil il a sorti beaucoup beaucoup
de bouquins sur sherlock holmes et
l'enquêteur le plus connu de l'univers
s'est inspiré tous les détectives privés
d'aujourd'hui en fait le manga par
exemple konan
si ça ne se voit pas que c'est inspiré
il ya aussi des films et des séries sur
sherlock holmes ce parce que c'est trop
bien écrit c'est malin quand tu lis ça
tu as l'impression d'être intelligent ça
j'aime bien ça traduisez le comme vous
voulez j'ai pris le chien des
baskerville parce que voilà il avait
sorti quatre romans et apprend suite des
centaines et des centaines de nouvelles
ca ca est ressorti à plus de 200 ans et
ça se lit comme du petit lait et son duo
avec watson
il ya un petit peu la logique la raison
et aussi l'humain et ces deux
personnages là il incarne tout ça ça
trop fort impossible d'être déçu à la
fin de sa vie malheureusement est un peu
parti en vrille parce que je vais vous
lire j'ai de plus en plus attirés par le
cultisme il prononce plus de 60
conférences en faveur du spiritisme et
fonde une librairie à londres uniquement
consacré au sujet malheureusement d'une
crédulité sans borne
il accorde sa caution au pire charlatans
sir arthur conan doyle meurt en 1930
huawei les partis dans des délires oui
pensez pouvoir prouver la vie après la
mort et y avait à l'époque est une sorte
de fake news sur le fait que les fait
exister une photo et lui il l'avait dit
mais oui regardez la photo ça existe les
faits je vais vous le prouver et partie
totalement au rythme et ça enlève rien
au génie de toutes ces oeuvres
c'est tellement du vrai divertissement
intéressant intelligent
voilà on retourne dans les dystopie avec
peut-être le dernier livre que j'ai lu
c'est margaret atwood la servante
écarlate que vous connaissez peut-être
pour la série qui s'appelle de rendre
mail stylesight l'adapter sur age bio
sur ocs en france et la série excellente
et c'est ça qui m'a donné envie de lire
le livre en fait j'ai vu un ou deux
épisodes et après je me dis ok salaires
intéressants s'adapter et j'ai pas du
tout été déçu bien au contraire c'est
arrivé clairement dans mon top 10
tellement ça m'a bouleversé ça raconte à
un monde où plus personne n'arrive à
faire d'enfant voilà la fécondité est
tombé à zéro et il ya un gouvernement
qui se crée autour de ça et qui
sélectionne les gens et qui les attribue
à des tâches il ya des gens qui vont
avoir du pouvoir il ya des gens ce
qu'ils arrivent à féconder notamment ce
personnage s'appelle 2 fred le
personnage de fret qui du coup arrive à
avoir des enfants et du coup elle est
attribuée au rôle de ces reventes c'est
à dire qu'en fait les gens qui ont du
pouvoir ont le droit de la féconder mais
elle fait pas partie de la famille le
mec a quand même une femme etc
elle est juste là pour procréer c'est
très intéressant d'avoir créé une
dystopie par le spectre de la fécondité
ces femmes-là et de leur vie aussi
d'avancer passionnant la saison une de
la série télé c'est l'équivalent de ce
tome la voilà donc s'ils ne met pas lire
à la limite l'histoire est tellement
passionnant que vous
la série ne dirais pas souvent ce genre
de conseils c'est quand même très très
bien exécuté mais les figures de style
qu'utilise margaret atwood c'est
fabuleux ses sorties en 85 je crois mais
c'est juste bluffant restons dans les
adaptations que tout le monde connaît
alors là ça tu peux le prendre à la
gueule tu fais moins ton malin je pense
pouvoir a sommé qui que ce soit avec ça
tu connais game of thrones non tu ne
connais pas je vais vous parler du trône
de fer j'ai vu la première saison à
l'époque il ya dix ans du coup du trône
de fer game of thrones et j'ai voulu ne
pas attendre je parle j'ai pas pu
attendre pour savoir la suite et je suis
tombé du coup là dedans
george rr martin un auteur de fou qui
arrive à créer des univers et des liens
avec des personnages il ya du
fantastique il ya plein de choses ça
prend aux tripes vraiment tu veux savoir
la suite j'aime beaucoup l'idée de
chaque chapitre est un personnage donc
soit c'est un nouveau personnage c'est
un personnage que tu connais bien et il
ya plein de rebondissements si vous
connaissez la série vous savez qu'il ya
des têtes qui tombent à tire larigot que
ça c'est george rr martin qui adore
couper des têtes
et ce qui est très marrant avec le trône
de fer ont déjà passionnant impossible
d'être déçu par sa c'est que la série
s'est terminée mais le dernier livre
n'est pas encore sorti donc en fait tout
le monde moi compris à temps là la faim
en livres et j'espère qu'elle va arriver
un jour tout simplement et je la lyre
est quand même parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de petites différences et de subtilité
qu'il n'y a pas dans la série la cei a
été très bien sauf la fois bien
évidemment je t'apprends rien le livre
va beaucoup plus loin dans la
psychologie dans certains personnages et
aussi des histoires un petit peu
parallèle qui sont pas pareils
exactement donc ça c'est vraiment 10 sur
10 et ça fait un petit peu les muscles
si tu lis les intégrales comme ça
j'adore
vous connaissez mon amour pour le japon
et il ya une oeuvre qui m'a vraiment
marqué là dedans 1,84 de haruki murakami
ça c'est absolument ouf 1,84 c'est trois
livres ok ça se suit c'est une histoire
qui est grande comme ça ce mec là écrit
des histoires très très étrange très
bizarre avec des tueurs en série avec
des sectes avec des trucs paranormaux
mais c'est passionnant et surtout ils
racontent beaucoup de choses du japon à
travers ces histoires par exemple là ça
parle notamment de secte en fait ça fait
écho à une tragédie qui s'est passé
là-bas y avec des dizaines d'années
c'est une secte qui a commis un attentat
dans le métro à tokyo sa marque et
beaucoup les gens et du coup en fait il
arrive à raconter ça aussi dans ce livre
là il ya un contexte un petit peu
bizarre donc j'adore comprendre plus sur
une culture ou une époque où une manière
de penser via des romances à sainté
partie 1,84 ses excellents top 4 de mes
livres préférés
philip k.dick ubik voulait un ticket
resto de 2011
ça vous intéresse ou pas philip k.dick
donc c'est un auteur qui m'a passionné
ses oeuvres ont énormément influencé
toute la science fiction ubik et je
trouve encore plus particulier parce
qu'en fait il ya toutes les thématiques
très étrange de ces livres qui sont
réunies en une seule histoire qui part
dans tous les sens je ne saurais même
pas vous pitch est le truc tellement
c'est étrange il va utiliser des thèmes
comme bah forcément l'humanité mais
aussi le voyage en tant la réalité tout
ça et avec des personnages ou si vous
connaissez pas flepia dit qu'il vous
connaissez forcément ses heures il a
fait attention total recall a été adapté
avec sursis n'est guère blade runner le
plus grand film de science fiction de
tous les temps pour beaucoup de gens el
cheikh avec ben affleck très mauvais
film mais très bon livre the man in the
right now qui est adapté en série sur
amazon prime bref c'est un auteur qui a
beaucoup beaucoup marqué les gens et
unique n'a jamais été adapté parce que
c'est je pense que c'est inadaptable
sais m'en fous que voilà ça fait un
livre absolument unique
j'ai eu un petit peu des bio sur philip
k.dick beaucoup de consommation de
psychotropes et d'un de drogues dures
très étrange et il était très
paranoïaque fois l'élève l'impression
que tout le monde faisait des complots
contre lui je pense que ça a beaucoup
nourri ces histoires malheureusement
pour sa santé mais bien heureusement
pour ces histoires qui sont absolument
incroyable ça c'est ouf mais si je dois
vous conseiller un autre livre de k dick
parce que les androïdes rêvent de
boutons mécaniques je crois que ça le
titre blade runner en anglais et il
serait assez différente du film
voilà c'est ce genre de livre que
j'adore ce top 3 il m'a tellement
touchée c'est incroyable je vous parlais
de isaac asimov qui est probablement
l'auteur de sf le plus connu ce qui est
très connue de lui c'est le cycle des
robots voilà c'est plein de livres et de
nouvelles qui parle des robots de
comment ils agissent dans le futur et il
a créé du coup ce qu'on appelle les lois
d'asimov aujourd'hui qui sont des doigts
de robotique qui sont utilisés
énormément aujourd'hui par les
ingénieurs qui créent des intelligences
artificielles donc c'est dire à quel
point il est assez visionnaire mais ce
que je préfère moi ces fondations je
vais vous pitié l'histoire et vous allez
trouver ça vous si vous connaissez pas
déjà
ça se passe dans le turf eu les hommes
ont fui la planète terre y lit sur une
sorte d'énorme planète faite de métal
qui sont construites avec des vaisseaux
spatiaux tout ça et là y'a un chercheur
qui arrivent et qui dit les gars y'a un
truc qui est celle où la saga des les
statistiques on va droit dans le mur ça
va être la fin de la civilisation telle
qu'on la connaît et les hommes sont
partis pour trente mille ans de dèche
après que tout se soit effondré le
gouvernement qui découvrent six ans et
qui fument commence à 30 millions de la
dèche c'est chiant quand même le
chercheur effet attendez les gars vous
inquiétez pas si vous me filer trois
fois rien c'est à dire une planète et
quelques chercheurs - les trente mille
ans de la dèche
je voulais transforme en milan bondit
lupa plus gouvernement lui dis ok tiens
je te file une fois une planète qui
s'appelle fondations et des chercheurs
vont dessus ils vivent là ils colonisent
une sorte de petite planète et tout ce
que dit ce fameux chercheurs qui
s'appelle hari seldon se réalise le
monde s'effondre les humains partent à
la dérive
les connaissances disparaissent les gens
mangent des cailloux ce que ça va pas
durer trente mille ans mais milan grâce
à fondation cette planète avec peu de
chercheurs
qu'est ce qui est intéressant c'est de
voir ensuite toute la suite parce qu'il
ya la suite de fondations c'est en tout
trois livres 3 même plus parce qu'il a
fait des prêts qu'elle est tout comme
samantha et trois livres principaux de
fondations qui raconte du coup
l'histoire de l'humanité qui essayent de
s'en sortir de voir comment elle évolue
après c'est milan de dèche à manger des
cailloux c'est passionnant ça vraiment
inspiré beaucoup de gens et j'ai appris
que apple d'adapter en séries télé je
suis très intrigués de voir ça excellent
asimov on auteur de science fiction
préférée
on arrive sur un auteur qui pareille m'a
beaucoup beaucoup marqué kafka alors je
vais vous parler de son livre qui
s'appelle le procès mais je ne l'est pas
je les ai perdus je sais pas où il est
du coup j'ai pris une nouvelle que
j'avais dans ma bibliothèque s'appelle
la métamorphose que j'avais adoré franz
kafka est connu pour un genre d'histoire
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui kafkaïen c'est
son nom de famille est devenu un
adjectif c'est fou il crée des histoires
où tu marches sur la tête c'est à dire
que tu te retrouves dans un engrenage
que tu ne peux pas comprendre tu en
viens à questionner si c'est les gens
qui sont fous ces sétois qu'il faut dans
le procès c'est l'histoire d'un procès
c'est un mec qui est accusé mais il ne
sait pas de quoi il est accusé et il se
retrouve dans un engrenage d'un système
il essaye de se défendre mais c'est plus
de quoi est en fait plus ils essayent
puis ça s'enferme sur lui c'est
absolument dingue le procès la
métamorphose c'est aussi une nouvelle
que moi j'avais adoré c'est très simple
c'est un mec qui se transforme en
scarabée ou en insectes on sait pas trop
c'est très étrange dit comme ça mais le
génie de kafka c'est qu'il écrit un mec
qui un matin il se réveille n'arrive pas
à se retourner sur le ventre il est
coincé sur le dos parce que ben ali est
devenu un scarabée géant le premier tube
qui se disent et mère je vais être en
retard au boulot voilà tu te reçoivent
un scarabée telle a fait [ __ ] merde
encore comment je vais être à l'heure
moi ça fait chier et tous les
personnages autour de l'intrigué sont
l'agent non mais vas-y nous foulons
monte lui à devenir un scarabée
c'est du tipi de kafka est aussi un
autre livre qui s'appelle le château qui
raconte l'histoire d'un mec qui a un
rendez vous dans un château mais la rage
pas rentrer dedans et du coup tout
devient fou autour de lui d'une grande
carcasse qui est intéressant c'est que
le procès et le château
il ne l'a jamais terminé en réalité
c'est à dire qu'il a créés tous les
chapitres il a demandé à sa mort de ne
pas aller dit et de tout brûler en fait
et heureusement son meilleur ami elle
n'a pas écouté ses ordres il a préféré
éditer ses livres bien heureusement
parce que moi c'est une littérature et
c'est des histoires et c'est qu'ils sont
passionnantes qui m'ont beaucoup
beaucoup touché voilà moi j'adore franz
kafka incroyable là je vais vous parler
de mon livre préféré et de mon auteur
préféré
c'est compris ça va être une dystopie
c'est 1984 arts georges orwell sage
l'élu vraiment un paquet de fois et là
c'est une nouvelle traduction qui vient
de sortir et donc j'étais ravie de me
replonger dans l'histoire c'est une
dystopie c'est un monde où un
gouvernement contrôle tout et chaque
individu est surveillée par des petites
caméras chez eux un petit bon partout et
il ya des posters et des affiches du
dictateur partout qui s'appelle big
brother qui ressemble un peu à staline
quoi c'est une grosse moustache et tout
ça tout est contrôlé et il ya beaucoup
de propagande et tout ça et c'est un
personnage qui vit là dedans et qui
essayent s'en sortir qui va faire des
rencontres les chapitres sont
bouleversants à l'intérieur et des
moments vraiment ça tout ça te prend aux
tripes je te dis mais c'est fou qu'est
ce qui va se passer le plus connu après
1184 c'est bien sûr la ferme des animaux
ce sont des animaux dans une ferme qui
décident de se rebeller qui décide de
devenir humain en quelque sorte ils
veulent parler ils veulent choisir pour
eux et tout ça et bien sûr c'est une
forme de dictature qui revient un petit
peu en place c'est une thématique est
très cher pour lui pourquoi parce qu'en
fait quand on découvre ces deux autres
libres s'appelle dans la dèche à paris à
londres et ça raconte son quotidien de
sdf à paris et à londres et c'est
passionnant on voit qu'il a été
galériens dans des rues que tu peut
emprunter aujourd'hui il a dormi par
terre alors que c'est l'un des auteurs
les plus influents du monde et ensuite
hommage à la catalogne voilà c'est un
peu dur à lire c'est lui qui va
s'engager sur le front en espagne pour
combattre les fascistes et il se prend
une balle dans la gorge il ya plein de
choses qui se passent pour lui dans sa
vie raconte aussi beaucoup de déception
vis-à-vis de la politique
tout ça parce que essayer de défendre
des idées en s'engageant et ça c'est un
peu retourné contre lui telle une balle
de fusil
donc ce mec-là a fait la guerre il a
voyagé un peu partout dans le monde il
est devenu sdf dans les rues de paris et
de londres et il te sort de roman qui
sont absolument incroyable et notamment
celui ci qui est pour moi le point
culminant de la dystopie parce qu'il ya
juste ce qu'il faut de romantisme et de
en fait on voit qu'il a vécu beaucoup de
choses et qu'il est l'ami la l'intérieur
qu'il a beaucoup mûri tout ça
malheureusement il est mort l'année
d'après de la sortie de 1134 1984 qui
est sorti en 1949
lisez ça absolument voilà si ce n'est
pas déjà fait tous les livres dans le
top à part un ou deux je les ai lus
vraiment plusieurs fois c'est validé par
le youtube heures numéro 2 de france
merci d'avoir suivi cette petite vidéo
j'espère que ça va peut-être vous
motiver un petit peu lire et n'hésitez
pas dans les commentaires à me raconter
aussi beau livre qui vous ont marqué
votre top 10 par exemple je cherche
toujours des livres à lire et donc je
suis toujours intéressé des petits
conseils alors bien évidemment il ya
plein plein d'auteurs que j'ai pas pu
rentrer dans un top 10 d'ailleurs ce top
10 est voué à évoluer on sait pas y
avoir d'autres livres qui vont arriver
et qui vont aussi me marquer me
bouleverser j'adore par exemple stephen
king bien évidemment tolkien en français
j'adore daniel pennac j'ai beaucoup aimé
récemment jake adelstein qui a écrit
tokyo rice qui raconte lui un
journaliste américain qui est confrontée
la mafia japonaise dans la science
fiction
ray bradbury richard matheson tout ça
c'est des gens qui sont incroyables qui
ont écrit l'histoire des nouvelles
absolument folle en science fiction en
français il ya pierre boulle qui a fait
la planète des singes ou barjavel voilà
bref beaucoup de livres que j'adore et
d'ailleurs n'hésitez pas à me dire aussi
si vous voulez d'autres tops par exemple
sur ben mes films préférés mais jeux
vidéo préférés les mangas préférés les
animés préférés je ne sais pas n'hésitez
pas à me le dire voilà moi je vous
souhaite de bonnes vacances si vous
regardez cette vidéo l'été et on se dit
à très vite pour des sketches et des
fictions et ce genre de choses ciao bye
mais je sais pas comment tu as mené
cette vidéo je sais plus comment on fait
ça [ __ ]
[Musique]